hello everyone and welcome to a quick
reminder of just how strong Bobby Fisher
was this is the highest ever ratings
list from 27chess.com and you can see
that Magnus Carlsen tops the rating list
with 28 89.2 which was reached on 21st
of April at 2014 so almost 10 years ago
but you can see that almost all of these
Peak ratings were achieved sometimes uh
after the year 2000 so it's um everyone
achieved this rating after the year
2000. okay we have Anatoly karpova who
had his Peak rating in 1994 but then you
have Bobby Fischer who had a rating of
almost 2 800 27 89.7 and 4th of August
1972 that's 51 years ago and yes ratings
are much much higher now if you remember
in those days um when Fisher played
against basket Fisher was like 115
rating points higher rated than sposky
that's just how how um uh further ahead
he was uh ahead of the playing field so
that's the reminder hope you enjoyed it
see you soon